[Music]
on this friday night
will summer be a bummer or is there hope
on the horizon
we certainly have to be very careful
canada's top doctors on weather
restrictions should be relaxed
as vaccinations and temperatures rise
more
innocent lives lost in the middle east
the amplifying threats
and pleas for peace canadian boxers
battle
outside the ring i want to go to tokyo
the decision keeping her from competing
at the olympics that's being called
sexist and not a scaredy cat the
fearless feline
fleeing a burning building
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
on a night there are hopeful signs the
end of the pandemic
is inching into sight canada's chief
public health officer says
this country may have passed the peak of
the third wave
the latest weekly average of the
national daily case counts is down more
than
20 percent from the peak last month and
dr theresa tamm says more than 50
percent of adults
have now received at least one dose of a
vaccine
in fact vaccinations are ramping up
across the country
and canada's health minister says it's
now time to start talking
about what a post-vaccinated canada
could look like
but this is a road map for canadians
this gives canadians a vision
of what it looks like as we proceed down
this vaccination path together
what kinds of activities we can
anticipate we can enjoy without worrying
about either catching covid or
transmitting covid
restrictions will only be reduced if we
reach new vaccine targets
abigail beeman breaks down the reopening
road map and
what it means for your summer mask-less
and
up close fully vaccinated americans can
do pretty much anything they want
says the u.s centers for disease control
and prevention
while in canada while we've been waiting
months for any guidance
we got this friday if 75 percent of us
have one dose and 20 percent have two
we can hike camp picnic and patio
probably what you did during last year's
no-dos summer
we're still in the battling the third
wave right and so the case counts are
high
the health care systems in certain parts
of the country are
still sort of close to the breaking
point so that's why we uh
we certainly have to be very careful it
would be really helpful
if that message of one shot summer was
paired
with what it actually means for people
in their real lives the country's
biggest city made a decision with a big
impact on people's real lives toronto is
cancelling all major summer events
it wasn't a surprise that they canceled
it we didn't want that to happen
and we made it through to effectively
labor day and i hope that
poster day will be a whole new world for
fall
the new guidance shows indoor gatherings
including sports and attending
university
are on the table if three quarters of us
are fully vaccinated i think math might
be the last layer of that multi-layer
protection
that would advise for people to remove
while the guidelines are extremely
non-specific
canada's top doctor teresa tam called
them aspirational
giving people something to look forward
to she also stressed
vaccination rates are only one indicator
of course
real-time coveted rates in places across
the country
will inform provinces and territories
own decisions
abigail beeman global news ottawa
on the vaccine front though more doses
are on the way and
earlier than expected next week canada
is scheduled to receive 4.5 million
doses of covid19 vaccines
from pfizer and moderna as provinces
continue to ramp up their immunization
efforts
3.4 million doses are going to come from
pfizer and 1.1 million
from moderna and new preliminary
research shows
waiting for a second dose of the pfizer
biontech vaccine
may offer older people more protection
the british study which has not been
peer reviewed
looked at 175 people over the age of 80
half were given their second shot at the
three week mark
the other half were given it at 12 weeks
researchers found the antibody responses
of those who waited was three and a half
times greater than those who had the
final dose within
pfizer's recommended time frame but
antibodies are just
one part of the immune system vaccines
also generate
t cells that destroy infected cells
researchers found
t-cell responses were weaker when the
second dose was delayed
the study's author says more research is
needed to understand
which vaccine interval is optimal
alberta hospitals are facing growing
pressure as that province continues to
grapple with its third wave
there are a record number of patients in
intensive care
and while the peak may still be weeks
away as heather urex west reports
jason kenney's government is instead
having to focus on
internal political unrest
inside edmonton's graynon's hospital icu
nurse
andrea irwin can hardly believe what
she's seeing each shift
it's really um
shocking actually to see so many people
so sick and and we're looking after
people who don't have covet
and we're looking after a lot of people
who have covets alberta's icus are now
seeing a record number of patients 177
on may 12
up from the province's second wave peak
of 151 back in december
and because the number of new daily
infections has been high
for weeks the pressure on hospitals is
only set to rise
the icu admission number has been around
0.7 percent of the total
so 7 out of every thousand but then
what's not factored into that really yet
is the
the impact of variance which has a
higher risk for isu admission
but this week the focus of alberta's
government has been somewhere else
entirely members of premier jason
kenny's caucus spent much of thursday
in an emergency meeting after former
caucus chair todd lowen publicly called
on the premier to resign
in the end caucus voted to boot both
lowen and mla drew
barnes another backbencher who has been
a vocal opponent of government policies
i regret that that it had to come to
this but
i respect the decision our caucus has
made and we're going to move on focused
on
the priorities of the public the
dissension among kenny's ranks has been
simmering for weeks
last month 16 caucus members signed a
letter decrying the government's coveted
restrictions
so removing two of the 16 is not likely
to make the premier's problems go away
it's just postponing the the eruption of
more
dissension i think down the road until
then the premier has more pressing
matters at hand
as the health system braces for what is
likely to be a very
difficult month ahead heather urex west
global news
calgary after alberta manitoba has the
second highest infection rate in canada
the province recorded 491 new cases in
the past 24 hours
and today health officials released new
modeling showing manitoba's daily cases
are exceeding the extreme scenario at
the peak modeling shows around 50 new
covet hospitalizations
per day by mid to the end of july and
seven to eight admissions to the icu per
day by mid-july
the extreme case scenario still sees
around 300 new coveted cases a day by
the start of september
today manitoba opened vaccinations to
children 12 and under
manitoba's top doctor says approximately
20 percent of the cases in the province
are in school-aged children the world
health organization is urging rich
countries to reconsider plans to
vaccinate children and instead donate
covet 19
shots understand why some countries want
to vaccinate their children
and adolescents but right now
i urge them to to reconsider
and to instead donate vaccines to kovacs
is the global initiative to get vaccines
to countries in need
a canadian shipment of medical aid has
arrived in india
the containers are filled with around
300 ventilators and thousands of vials
of the anti-viral drug from desevere
today total infections in india climbed
above 24 million
overburdened hospitals are turning away
patients because
oxygen tanks and beds are in short
supply the country's health care system
is paralyzed by the highly transmissible
b-1617 variant india's prime minister
says his government is on
war footing to try to contain it another
day if intense violence is unfolding in
the middle east
israeli jets pummeled gaza with targeted
hits on key infrastructure
including a tunnel network used by hamas
relentless rocket attacks on israeli
towns were intercepted by the
iron dome missile defense system and the
death toll is rising on both sides
there are reports at least 122 people in
gaza have died since monday that
includes 31 children
and in israel at least eight people
including a soldier have been killed
the israeli military is building up
ground forces on the border with gaza
suggesting
tensions could escalate to a full-blown
war
diplomatic efforts are intensifying too
but as
eric sorensen reports the violence is
spreading
a hamas compound was hit today by
israeli bombs
and gaza's national production bank was
blown up new setbacks for hamas
militarily
but the attacks are also devastating for
the people of gaza
buildings turn to rubble and dozens
killed including children
many families have sought refuge in this
u.n relief agency school
artillery was hitting from every side
she said she had to bring her children
to safety
hamas too has demonstrated firepower
israeli officials say the militants have
already fired more than 1800 rockets
in sterot near the border this building
was struck
my home was hit says this woman 20 years
after the first rocket
the kids are being damaged for life
both sides have the advantage and
disadvantage of proximity
israel has multiple air bases locations
in gaza can be attacked within minutes
but hamas rockets while less accurate
can target border towns like zdarot
with little warning and they can reach
heavily populated areas including tel
aviv and beyond
then there is israel's ground forces
they can build up on the border with
gaza
quickly not far from starat
israeli tanks and troops have been
gathering for days already destroying
hamas tunnels
their presence an ominous sign that an
all-out war is looming
prime minister benjamin netanyahu said
again today that hamas will pay a heavy
price
his political future is at stake an
opposition party has been asked to form
a government
a decisive outcome militarily could help
netanyahu politically
but there is instability elsewhere in
israel unrest in jerusalem
and mobs of jewish and arab israelis are
fighting each other in several cities
it's all putting pressure on the
international community to intervene
quickly the u.n security council meets
on sunday
the only way that it's going to resolve
is through negotiations there would need
to
be willingness on both sides
to step back but at the moment no one is
stepping back
eric sorensen global news toronto
nurses are the heart and soul of the
health care system
but the weight of the pandemic is
crushing their story coming up
it's more powerful evidence of the toll
the pandemic is taking on health care
workers
they're on the job around the clock to
provide care and comfort to those who
need it most
but it can be an immense burden and it
doesn't end when their shift is over
during this national nurses week global
news is shining a light
on those struggling to protect others
and themselves
here's ross lord as a nurse sarah
waldgee has shouldered more than her
share of the pandemic
you're working 60 to 110 hours a week
and i know that's just not myself it's a
bunch of colleagues as well
in addition to being a public health
nurse walgie is a psychiatric nurse in
oakville ontario
encountering more patients with urgent
mental health crises
eventually became too much i was having
quite a lot of
abdominal pain quite a lot of fatigue as
well
you just felt chronically tired and
that's coupled with burnout
after cutting back on her work week she
felt guilty
i shouldn't be burnt out this early in
my career i shouldn't be going through
this
um so then that aspect of guilt was in
where it's like i don't want my
colleagues to have to ever go through
this especially in a healthcare system
that's chronically understaffed
nationwide before covert 19 there were
signs of improvement
the number of regulated nurses in canada
actually increased by 1.9 percent
between 2018 and 2019
to a total approaching a half million
but the pandemic
is producing troubling stats in a survey
of 2100 nurses conducted in ontario in
february
almost all respondents reported stress
from the pandemic
and at least 13 percent of registered
nurses aged 26 to 35
said they're very likely to leave the
profession after the pandemic is over
that's four times the normal rate of
attrition for that age group
i get many phone calls at night because
i i am a representative of our union
in our site and uh they're crying the
nurses are
going home crying the ontario nurses
association says
the province has the lowest nurse to
patient ratio in canada
labor unions say the ford government's
promise to improve health care staffing
is undercut by other realities like wage
restraints on current employees
they're limited this year to a one
percent wage increase under law
that doesn't apply to police it doesn't
apply to fire doesn't apply to
paramedics or other essential service
workers it applies to them
bulgie says some colleagues on the front
lines of the pandemic
have been overwhelmed to the point of
taking their own lives
she's feeling better these days hoping
canada turns the corner on the pandemic
soon
once and for all ross lord global news
tomorrow in part two ross looks at the
spike in students pursuing a career in
nursing
and whether more actions needed to
underscore the crucial role they play
why don't we just give free education
for health care workers health care
professionals
throughout the country for four six
years until we get
over this bump still ahead tonight why
canada could soon see a tsunami of
new cancer cases
you're watching global national
[Music]
the pandemic is taking a major toll on
hospital capacity across the country
and that's having a ripple effect on
patients not sick with covid19
cancer diagnostic tests and surgeries
are being delayed
the fear of catching the virus also has
some people postponing or
even canceling visits to the doctors
oncologists fear that that could lead to
a huge wave of cancer cases
with many too advanced to even treat
their warning
it's not worth the wait to get screened
it's patients like diane van kulin who
have doctors concerned
diane avoided going to hospital even
though she has cancer
because she was fearful of getting sick
with covid19
i refused to go in for four weeks and i
got sicker and sicker and my body became
more broken what would have happened if
i went in
at the beginning some of diane's tumors
tripled in size
she's now warning others not to wait
fear gets you nowhere
if you have the opportunity to get
treated that day
don't wait four weeks during the
pandemic
cancer screenings have been missed
surgeries delayed
symptoms ignored by would-be cancer
patients
according to the canadian institute for
health information from march to june of
2020
the number of cancer surgeries were down
20 percent across the country
dr antoine skander is a surgical
oncologist he's been collecting data on
new diagnoses
oncology surgeries and screening tests
being done
during the pandemic it's been described
as there's going to be a tsunami of
cancer cases after we get out of this
copic crisis
i don't disagree with that i think there
will be an uptick
of identifying these patients that have
not been diagnosed yet but the question
is
are we going to identify them at a point
where there's very little we can do
and that's what scares us i would gladly
take a tsunami
of patients that needed treatment and
sorting out how we would do that
over patients who we've missed who now
can't get treatment
and we just don't know yet how that's
going to pan out
it's so interesting that you're saying a
backlog or a tsunami would be actually a
good thing
compared to what you think could
potentially happen exactly
i would almost welcome a tsunami because
i think we would find a way to make it
work
the pandemic has also impacted a
seven-year-old boy who couldn't get a
stem cell donation because of travel
restrictions
how his family saved his life saturday
on the new reality at 7 p.m
right here on global
boxing the patriarchy next one athlete's
battle to prove women
don't have to pick between family and
career
they say cats have nine lives while this
fearless feline may have lost a few
the black cat you just saw jumped out of
the fifth floor window of a burning
building in chicago and
somehow landed safely on the grass below
bouncing
before running off firefighters say the
furry friend hid under a car for several
minutes
and doesn't appear injured they are now
trying to track down its owner
a canadian boxer is in the biggest
fighter for life but it's outside the
ring
mandy bujold says she lost her spot on
the team competing at the tokyo olympics
because
she chose to have a family bujold
believes she's the victim of gender bias
and she's launched a legal battle
here's mike drollet on her hurdle ahead
twice a day every day mandy bourgeois
trains with an
unwavering focus the tokyo olympics has
always been her goal
win a medal for canada and then retire
it's that
last fight too right like i want to go
to tokyo because i want
that to be you know my the final moment
in my career the end of this chapter in
my life
it's a chapter that's now being written
without her because the international
olympic committee recently decided to
use the results from tournaments held in
2018 and 2019
to determine who qualifies except
boujold wasn't fighting then
she was pregnant with her daughter kate
her olympic dream
she learned in an email was over do you
feel let down by the olympic movement
i do i honestly i do and it's
unfortunate i think you know being an
olympian has always been something i've
been super proud of
before getting pregnant she was the
number two fighter in the americas
as well as a quarter finalist in the rio
olympic games in 2016.
she thought the ioc had made a mistake
however she was told if they made an
exception for her
they'd have to make it for everyone the
argument that this is somehow
going to cause unfairness for everyone
else they're gonna have to if they
change the rule for this case the
floodgates will open and they'll get all
these appeals for real changes
well what floodgates how many people are
getting pregnant pujold isn't alone in
her corner
tennis icon billie jean king has
expressed support and the canadian
olympic committee and
minister of heritage have sent letters
to the ioc
but will the ioc listen earlier this
year the head of the tokyo organizing
committee was forced to resign
after making sexist comments in response
the ioc made a point of stressing its
commitment to women's issues
urging each competing country to have a
male and female flag bearer
and calling tokyo the first gender equal
olympic games the legal angle
for mandy is not a fairness issue
it's a human right violation violation
of the olympic charter issue
because of the pregnancy bujold has
filed an appeal with the court of
arbitration for sport
in boxing she's never backed away from a
fight
as a mother it's out of the question so
i'm trying to be that example for her to
show her hey when she looks back on this
you know later in life and says
wow like my mom did that right
microlight global news kitchener ontario
and what an example she is and a
trailblazer
that is global national for this friday
night i'm fary nasser and tonight's your
canada
is the sunrise in montreal we love
seeing your canada so please keep
sending us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks so much for making us part of
your evening robin gill will be with you
tomorrow
until next friday take care of
yourselves and each other